filmmaking is a disease and you have to
be sick and I'm super sick
[Music]
the first thing that I would tell an
aspiring filmmaker is to educate
yourself be permeable to what is around
you with humility with respect and with
also an ability to see yourself in that
world so that that world trusts you
that's key
I want to do this master class to
demystify the process
welcome to the workshop of the queen of
katwe we're doing one scene to show how
to direct actors
actors look for the ability to trust
your work as a director is to create a
space where they are allowed to bloom
when I'm budgeting the picture I'm not
going to let people see my struggle my
formula is every scene has to do more
than one thing every scene has to do
three things
films under the guise of entertainment
should open windows in your heart
nothing is more powerful than seeing
your own language your own color your
own people your own dramas on screen
if you don't tell your own story no one
else will
I'm Mira Nair and this is my master
class
[Music]
[Music]